oi será que você tá usando todo seu
potencial todos os dias para encontrar
amigos me falando e quem nunca teve
amigos nesse sentido também nossa
precisa ter uma grande ideia essa grande
ideia vai mudar a forma de agir você
mais feliz não queria atingir meus
objetivos na e a tecnologia veio à tona
e todo mundo fala nossa agora é só
tecnologia eu vou criar meu aplicativo
vou criar o meu software eu vou criar o
meu rádio e todos os dias mas você é
bombardeado com essas informações se
você não usar o digital ou se você não
sal tecnologia sua empresa vai morrer
você precisa usar essa tecnologia isso
tudo é muito bom realmente gera
resultados impressionantes mas será que
são são as fatores intrínsecos que são
elementos importantes para o sucesso do
seu negócio do seu
em qualquer coisa que você queira
atingir será que são somente esses
fatores extrínsecos como meritocracia
ganhar mais é um premiações que fazem a
gente atingirem os maiores patamares
nesse ponto é muito interessante uma
reflexão às vezes a gente voltar e
pensar sai mucinic coloca uma frase que
eu gosto bastante ele colocar que as
empresas elas são formadas por seres
humanos os seres os seus clientes são
humanos os seus colaboradores são
humanos seu cliente um humanos ele
coloca sintetizando tudo isso o que você
quer entender negócios você quer atingir
o resultado você precisa entender
pessoas se você precisa parar para
entender como essas pessoas pensam como
essas pessoas agem porque elas agem esse
ponto é a emoção do ser humano que
gerando resultados em negócios e gerando
resultados em empreendimentos como um
todo vem sendo estudado já algum tempo
ah entendeu ficou super famoso com o
livro justiça que os seus dilemas que
não são dele já vinham antes mas usou
muito e deu popularizou nas suas aulas
em harvard mostrando vários dilemas de
mostram que a emoção norteiam as
decisões do ser humano no brasil a gente
tem neurocientista as impressionantes
pedro calabresa um deles que ele coloca
uma alguns exemplos bem legais de
mostrarem como é a todos nossas decisões
estão enraizadas e e os grandes líderes
e entendem que as pessoas tomam decisões
agem de acordo com emoções ele colocou
exemplo contrapondo que a gente colocou
no começo da nossa conversa né da
inteligência individual dia que vai ser
a grande ideia que vai mudar acho que
vai ser a grande ideia para revolucionar
ele faz uma brincadeira falando poxa
será que foi a inteligência individual
que nos trouxe até aqui se ele pegasse o
albert einstein e colocasse lá nas
savanas africanas meus que poderia dar
qualquer livro para ele todos os livros
do mundo para ele que ele não
sobreviveria e enfatiza a grande
importância a gente tem g
o laborativa é a colaboração entre as
pessoas é a união entre as pessoas que
geram grandes feitos grandes
empreendimentos é super importante esses
elementos intrínsecos quando você quer
fazer grandes feitos atingir grandes
resultados é aquela questão da empatia
que a gente sempre fala mas às vezes não
coloca em prática empatia é você ter
nada mais é do que você entender o outro
pagar para olhar para o outro e ter
respeito por que você não é paciente
viver o que o outro vive porque você não
tem naquele contexto de vida você não tá
errado no cérebro da outra pessoa mas é
respeitar entender as diferenças isso
tem um peso muito grande confiança
confiança move a economia aí com a
confiança uni as pessoas é o propósito é
o mostrar que existe algo maior que eu
que você que todos os outros e que une
dessas pessoas podem atingir objetivos
grandes pode transformar é aquela coisa
de
e para tirar a sessão é aquela coisa de
motivar as pessoas reunidas pessoas para
poder atingir os peitos que a gente
pretende isso é é muito forte na
economia né se trazem dados e várias
informações mostrando que os países que
têm grande desempenho econômico são os
países em que as pessoas confiam mais
uma nas outras uma existe o também traz
engajamento para seu time interno para
que você consiga chegar em resultados
cada vez maiores e aqui na américa do
sul gente fala né nos países
desenvolvidos em geral a gente coloca
muito isso é como o fator é confiança lá
fora é importante para o desenvolvimento
econômico mais aqui esse papel ainda
pode ser maior a gente tem uma sociedade
muito desigual muito dividida em que
essa consciência está cada vez mais
distanciando tornando os mercados
menores que produz um produto empreende
para um número limitado de pessoas e
você com criar colocando essas pessoas
juntas unidas participando e
o modelo juntas gerando uma relação de
confiança pode fazer com que você atinja
o número bem maior de pessoas aquele
efeito comunidade e muitos livros de
tecnologia colocam e que hoje é muito
bem colocado nada melhor do que com
criar criar confiança gerada
extremamente críticos para esse poderoso
resultado é muito interessante que a
gente falei para desenvolvimento de
olhar um mercado cada vez maior né a
gente olha que a tecnologia pode dirigir
muitas pessoas mas quantas pessoas fazem
uso a tecnologia com essa intensidade
será que a tecnologia tem relação de
confiança com todas as classes sociais
brasileiras ou será que é o criaram
participar junto que vai poder de chegar
num caminho muito maior isso se coloca
para ralar di ou trazendo aqui também
outros ensinamentos para lá de stuart
hart até unos curtindo os números a
tanto lucro eu acho que o lucro pode
transformar né não precisa tirar
elemento do lucro ou estava lá de coloca
a confiança é um pré-requisito nesse
países empresas de ver
o sucesso do brasil na no méxico e na
índia exatamente cocriando com áreas e
com as com classes sociais diferentes
para produtos mais complexos mais
diversos e que as pessoas participam e
confiam na ativa o poder da tecnologia
eu acho que você já estão acostumados
com diversas histórias por aí diversos
vídeos contendo sobre isso todas as três
coisas da transformação digital da
aproximação das pessoas pela tecnologia
vocês estão habituados a olhar então
agora a minha reflexão é essa esse poder
do olhar para o ser humano esse o poder
da diversidade esse poder da empatia que
é o entender e respeitar o próximo o
poder da co-criação porque a colaboração
a inteligência colaborativa ter uma
potência até um bem muito forte então
usar esses elementos podem te ajudar a
atingir resultados incríveis agora aqui
para ir mostrar e mostrar para vocês que
é possível eu gostaria de contar uma
história que a história de paraisópolis
se unindo
a dor como protagonista da própria
transformação atingindo resultados
incríveis para combater academia do
clube 19 o principal problema que as
favelas estão enfrentando nesse momento
no combate ao coronavírus é a falta de
uma política pública específica as suas
elas cresceram de forma desordenada sem
acesso à infraestrutura básica como
acesso a água por exemplo durante a
pandemia esses problemas são agravados
em pedem que a população possa cumprir a
quarentena com as recomendações estão
indicadas pelos órgãos de saúde diante
disso a comunidade em conjunto em
parceria com pessoas físicas e jurídicas
decidiram se unir e criar dez
iniciativas para criar uma grande rede
de solidariedade e apoiar a população
carente a combater o coronavírus nas
favelas brasileiras elas foram a
resposta para resolver cada um dos
problemas encontrados nas periferias por
um ações positivas para solucionar cada
um
bom então a primeira coisa que decidimos
a fazer foi a organização da comunidade
através dos presidentes de rua a cada 50
casas temos dois moradores voluntários
um presidente e o vice-presidente de rua
que cuidam da nossas famílias é muito
importante essa ação deles porque eles
são importantíssimos para poderem
concientizar a população a ficar em casa
e também realizar a última milha da
entrega de todos os bens recebidos por
doações então eles garantem uma entrega
porta a porta das cestas básicas das
marmitas e dos produtos de limpeza
evitando aglomeração e seguindo todas as
recomendações de isolamento e de higiene
nesse momento de pandemias são eles
também os responsáveis por acionar as
ambulâncias caso encontrem nessa área
monitorada alguém que possivelmente está
com coronavírus ou está passando por
algum problema de saúde exatamente
porque nessas áreas urbanas muitas vezes
o samu não chega e sabemos que
o atendimento rápido poderia salvar
milhares de vidas contratamos
ambulâncias privadas que ficam à
disposição da comunidade 24 horas por
dia essa ambulância fica 24 horas por
dia atendendo o chamado desses
presidentes de rua que gerenciam e
monitoram as microrregiões pela qual
eles são responsáveis também decidimos
criar e capacitar grupos de socorristas
com moradores locais para que eles
possam fazer um pré-atendimento
prestaram os primeiros socorros no caso
seja necessário e facilitar a chegada
dessas ambulâncias potencializando essa
ação do socorro médico contratado uma
outra iniciativa super importante e que
complementa a isso tudo é a criação de
casas de acolhimento que podem abrigar
até 520 pessoas elas funcionam e escolas
estaduais e para isso foram feitas
reformas que ficarão como legado para os
estudantes dessas regiões
e essas escolas recebem pessoas que
testaram positivo para o convívio
garantindo um isolamento emanam
contaminação de outros moradores e
garantindo o que essas pessoas em que
tenham afetado pela doença de forma leve
recebam todo o amparo necessário com
seis alimentações diárias área de
recreação com wi-fi área de jogos e
conseguiu se recuperar da melhor forma
possível ainda para evitar a
proliferação da doença criamos uma
iniciativa para confecção de máscaras
por meio de um projeto denominado
costurando os sonhos do brasil através
de um home office das costureiras o home
office específico e possível de ser
executado dentro das favelas do brasil
as costureiras levaram as máquinas para
sua casas estão se propondo a costurar
mais de 1 milhão de máscaras que serão
distribuídas gratuitamente nas favelas
em complemento a isso uma outra
iniciativa foi criada para absorver os
o que foram os mais atingidos
economicamente ficaram desempregados
para isso foi criado um outro programa
chamado adote uma diarista em um dia até
agora cerca de 1.030 e duas diaristas
foram adotados e recebem cestas básicas
e kits de higiene 150 delas já estão
recebendo um vale auxílio no valor de
300 reais que elas receberam durante
esses três meses para ajudar a superar
esse momento de crise agora dizendo
mitigar e diminuir esse problema do
desemprego estamos criando iniciativas e
buscando fortalecer o comércio local
para que a economia regional continue
forte para isso estamos estimulando as
pessoas que estão doando a comprar
diretamente no nosso comércio do
comércio das favelas e também estamos
estimulando os moradores continuarem a
comprar localmente em vez de comprar em
grandes redes do varejo e através disso
já fizemos uma distribuição de mais de
55mil marmitas distribuímos mais de dia
as cestas básicas todas compradas no
comércio regional última iniciativa
super importante está ligada a
fortalecimento da imunidade da população
e nesse ponto é realizado por um grande
empreendedor local que é o projeto de
impacto social mãos de marília que está
produzindo quase 10 mil marmitas
diariamente um de boa parte dessas
marmitas são compradas nos restaurantes
locais e distribuídas de forma gratuita
para toda a comunidade com isso criamos
uma grande rede de solidariedade eo
morador participa disso sendo o agente
da própria transformação e tudo isso
está atrelado ao g10 que é um grupo de
líderes comunitários das dez maiores
favelas do brasil e empreendedores de
impacto social que em 2018/2019 sonhava
em prosperar empreender de faturar um
desses últimos dois anos somados 14
bilhões de reais sete milhões a cada ano
ou seja o 110 propõe apresentar a favela
com uma
se propõe desenvolver a economia dessas
áreas urbanas as favelas elas podem
empreender podem gerar empregos e podem
alcançar transformação econômica e logo
transformação social para vocês terem
uma ideia se juntarmos todas as favelas
segundo outdoor social no ano passado as
favelas faturaram 120 milhões de reais é
um mercado muito grande e que ainda tem
espaço para um crescimento gigantesco e
pode ser ainda muito muito explorado ou
seja é possível empreender é possível
prosperar e ajudar a favela se
transformar e por isso que o dia dez
busca inspirar as pessoas a partir disso
e ter um propósito maior do que somente
realidades individuais nós percebemos
que papel do g10 durante a poderia era
muito importante e foi exatamente usando
essa colaboração as inteligência
colaborativa olhar por ser humano
primeiro para ajudar a salvar a economia
local e segundo para dar assistência à
população que mais precisa
e vamos ver que isso tudo deu certo
porque foram os moradores os líderes
estão atuando há muitos anos desse
território que ficou criaram e
participaram da modelagem dessa solução
e isso está acontecendo nesse momento eu
já te disse eu te pergunto a imagem só
esperar uma grande ideia como seria se
você parasse para olhar para o lado
entendesse melhor as pessoas usassem a
união passasse a criar uma grande rede
de colaboração para poder transformar
e aí